foreign
where am I
what am I doing
[Music]
what happened to me
Hello everybody welcome back to the
glitch detraction
I just woke up
we fell a long way and I don't know what
happened
we're in some kind of a basement here
and I'm beginning to think that the
escape room might not be part of this
anymore because I thought this was
supposed to be some kind of an
attraction
huh
Vanessa Addison Martin's Alfred Calvin
Johns her entrance was different less
nervous and more willing to talk I
noticed red stains on her clothes she
said they were red ink marks apparently
she has a very close relationship with
someone named will while she was talking
she had many nervous ticks and
stuttering which I did not see in the
previous meeting she was very happy to
talk about her life this time she
mentioned she was studying electronics
and mechanics with will I asked her
directly what her current job was today
it was the only thing she didn't want to
answer she talked about how she plans to
contact Fazbear entertainment to acquire
the attraction that closed in 2027. I
was wrong about her childhood it seems
she had a very good relationship and a
stable family sometimes while she thinks
she stares into my eyes for a long time
making the moment uncomfortable I will
mention it in the next meeting as she
left the room I noticed that she said
something to every person she saw people
say she was saying weird things
well
that's interesting oh look at all these
guys look at all these guys
beautiful well time to go in the ominous
red hallway of Doom
it's quiet in here okay
only
Robo only
emergency Joe's ah those little things
were Joe's I get it that makes perfect
sense
this is kind of disconcerting
just the sheer amount of quietness that
it is and the back rooms-esque nature of
it all
kind of curious what you're going to be
showing hey Joe's hi Jose
well I'm sure you won't be murderous and
scary
that's just for the animatronics of
which you certainly are not
probably
hello
I'm gonna get lost in here that's for
sure oh hi
an area footstep either
fascinating
nope
I'm assuming this is gonna lead me
somewhere eventually
I see you Jose
hi Joe's
oh I loaded all good
oh
[Music]
what's happening
oh hi
is this part of the attraction
hello
good to see you
my name is Markiplier okay
you wanna fist bump me that badly do you
oh
hello right click to recharge flashlight
ah
what if I just hold this down the whole
time oh
I powered that with my big strong
muscles
Press Bar near a pallet to pull it down
oh
oh you're going full on dead by daylight
here are you I feel like that's bigger
than it was before oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
fredbear's singing show
I don't know what I'm supposed to be
running away from but I'm not
particularly a fan of dead by daylight I
don't play it a lot I don't do a lot of
that I don't really do anything
oh
hey what's going on there what you doing
what's up with you
why
when when why please don't
I don't know how you spotted me he will
be patrolling the old Warehouse to find
you if you hear his footsteps get away
from there before he sees you he will
hear if you walk run or recharge your if
I walk if you connect the wrong fuse and
he is nearby he will hear it and come
closer remember to disconnect the wrong
fuse to stop the noise and make him go
away I don't know about that one I don't
know about that one so I can't even walk
what if I crawl it is here find the
truth
this is some escape room I don't know
what that means
light up
yes
[Music]
all right let's do this I guess
whoa
whoa whoa what is that
a king's Legacy Skydive gaming
well where's mine where's my crown
that's not my crown
that's not my crown all right so I need
fuses
okay how do I start this
oh god oh I'm doomed
okay I gotta I got a pallet though
okay I'm not a hey that's from the VR
okay I'm not 100 sure what I'm supposed
to do with that but there's a big old
box of fuses
next to it
just operating under the assumption that
it would be usable but apparently not
I'm clicking as hard as I can clack okay
so I'm guessing the things are on the
ground the things on the ground are
actual indications of where I need to go
probably green goes to here
oh frick
[Music]
oh God if he just if he rounds the
corner there's nothing I can do ain't a
damn thing to do about that
there ain't no damn thing to do okay
remember you can drop items by pressing
q i remember you never told me in the
first place this is brand new
information
you think that I know about this
okay let's try to so I'm just gonna do
this uh full noise
I see a blue line here so what that
what that probably means is that it
leads to a blue
uh reminder fix bugs before release oh a
cripper
I'm gonna wamp them
I'm gonna really womb stomp him who is
this who are these people why is Kratos
there that's interesting
the lore
all right come at me come at me bro I'm
gonna use oh I'm gonna I'm going the
wrong way
wow yeah pull down
oh you still go wait wait wait hold
on hold on that's what I thought and now
I actually move
uh interesting to Kyle what's up Kyle I
saw you lost your ID card so if you want
to take mine every time you have to get
in here I talked to Roger he said no
problem my ID card is on my desk I don't
know where your desk is
uh here's another one of these and still
more stuff I can't do I have a crowbar
though why
I was scratching my nose hold on hold on
hold on wait for it wait for it oh wait
for it wait for it wait for it
wait for it
wait whoa you slow down when you
recharge all right
you got me that time
I still don't know what to do there's no
like screen that comes up so I'm just
remember I can run whoa shoot I'm gonna
get this eventually I just gotta get
good at getting away from him that's all
I gotta do
don't matter how much noise I make
all I gotta do is get away from him
green green line suddenly
it's over there I hope he's coming
stomping
speed Speed Run oh God I have stamina I
have stamina
okay so you can't do that you can't run
forever
oh my God holy crap
go please okay
this doesn't matter no fuse
can't use no fuse can't use yeah yeah
catch your breath what is that key
I got a key
what
but that's not a fuse
that's not anything I was instructed to
use and it's glowing
just gotta go away
no matter what if I hear him I run in a
different direction the idea of this
purple key doesn't make a lot of sense
God damn it how did he spot me oh okay
this is gonna be a doozy you won't be
able to pick up fuses until you turn on
the monitors
[Music]
that seems like important information
that seems like really important
information
that seems like extremely pertinent
[Music]
how do I turn on the monitors is there a
solar panel
is there a solar panel no
that's the only mechanic that I've been
taught
that there would be a solar panel
Emmanuel's desk
oh they have names on them
okay
Patrick's desk okay they have names on
them Brendan's desk so the first step is
to find the person's desk
so I need to find John's desk
Mark's desk is it oh it's chica
oh my desk oh look at that
on my desk
John's desk here we go
where is it there it is uh if my crowbar
oh
bottom drawer but goddamn crowbar oh
frick I don't know if I saw the Crowbar
in all of my desk going
bar holy
got it
holy crap
you're doing great
okay
Ulfric no
no God
oh man you son of a John's desk
better be in the same goddamn place as
it was before Oh man oh wow oh wow I was
just getting it no of course I go the
One path that doesn't have any way out
of course I do oh of course
Susie's desk are these in the same spot
I don't know if the Crowbar is in the
same spot
where was it oh
where are you going
[Music]
oh
well that was rare
okay that was rare
got it back in a Flash not that bad
oh I see ah
okay
now I can do these
red red yellow
Maybe
a little blue red
blue red
freak freak oh god oh well oh my God are
you kidding me
pallet palette palette thank you
foreign
blue
man I can't see on these green green
oh are you kidding me
oh in the green slot of course God damn
it green blue yellow
green blue green blue yellow in the blue
slime okay and then green green blue
blue green blue blue green green blue I
thought it was this one yeah
no
in the Reds like green blue oh frick
wrong green blue green green blue
okay and there's also a purple key
I saw the door
that could house a purple key but who
knows where that is now
it does glow so if I do find it sure but
I'm not gonna waste my time unless it's
necessary which it might be okay
blue red yellow
that
in the red
yellow pink blue yellow yellow pink blue
in the green
and then
blue green blue
okay
what what how
I didn't see him at all oh my god oh
that was it God damn it where is it
where's my where's my freaking oh
this guy is the this is oh my God
this is infuriating
oh good thank you at least it gives me
that
oh boy oh frick oh frick come on
give it to me not that side
are you me frick
[Music]
wow intercepted
how the hell did you do that
how the hell did you intercept me like
that
this guy's deaths are always in the same
place great doesn't help me at all
because I'm not I'm past that man this
just reinforces the whole fact that I
really hate dead by daylight
blue
[Music]
are these not in here what is going on
green pink blue please tell me the
creepy nope okay
this one it was that one Frick oh my God
I can't
oh my God oh my God oh
stunning wait
what do you mean stunning Edward
what do you mean
what do you mean stunning eddard what do
you mean stunning entered
what
what do you mean
what do you mean stunning entered I I I
don't know how you would think that I
would glean information from that as to
how to accomplish said thing
I don't know what you mean
oh Red Green
two of them just gotta get this last one
that's actually by the door very
convenient
done
well where did that go
what was that
no no
not this time
[Music]
oh oh but I didn't get that but I didn't
get the key
oh that's gonna bite me in the ass
but I didn't get the key but I didn't
get the key
I go back
well let me make sure it saves first
hi
interesting
oh I see
no
I go back
I gotta go back